now a couple things about me what's up
daddy I'm wearing my sunglasses okay I
think you hit my stitches out today so
let me take my let me take my sunglasses
off and reveal the work better it's not
bad daddy of makeup who says inhale hold
on my dad needs a makeup I have a makeup
stick I went and bought at the pharmacy
bin there and I go my god I've been
there I buy the right color I don't
[ __ ] know I yeah well dude I was in a
hurry I'll take that one she goes she
was like are you sure I know they yeah
and I put it on him like my father I was
facedown my dad for Father's Day and my
father goes oh you look terrible you
look terrible you just swollen in the
face right now but it's getting so much
better so much better this ditches so I
had I was kept scrubbing my stomach I
got these two yellow spots while
scrubbing I go what the [ __ ] is this
surgical [ __ ] I kept scratching that
it's bruises from where they took the
fat on my [ __ ] eyes I got a belly fat
in my ah how big was the meal they took
you out I don't know I was in a way do
you have big marks though no they do it
in your bellybutton and they stick the
needle here oh oh oh [ __ ]
I really wasn't when I when I watch box
and someone needs like your nose job
like okay well you don't have enough
bone so what we're gonna do is we're
gonna cut a sliver out of your rare Mike
I'm gonna put in your nose if you helped
him just think you're off your rocker I
just picked some waking up we've had
many had broken ribs before yes it's
awful it's awful it's so loud you can't
laugh yeah nothing now this is me
pretending I've had broken ribs cuz I
want to be tough that's what I've had my
bruised ribs I've had kick ribs that is
it terrible it's so hard to breathe
you're just like you already saw the
Ritz and now I daddy had a septum he
couldn't breathe for three years and his
daddy wanted to try to fight yeah
Taekwondo got kicked in the face too
many times got my nose but I would love
to see daddy's okay so daddy would walk
oh the worst knocked out plenty of times
not in plane times five times in my life
but I walking around like this yeah all
the time and my friend Joey would be
like would you get your [ __ ] nose
fixed you keep doing this I couldn't
breathe
and I'm trying to sleep like this cuz I
couldn't I didn't feel good when you do
this though I think I can be so much
better
those those Neil Smith shot the Neil
Smith
Kansas City Chiefs he used to wear me
they make sense because when I just do
this a little bit I think 80% better
smelling well exactly cuz you've been
you've been fighting I go under the
knighting dr. diamond can do something
like this uh we'll talk to him well talk
to doctor but I I go under the knife I
come out my nose is like this I look
like a [ __ ] man pig how long ago was
that a while back this is god this is so
long ago this is 20 years ago more this
is probably yeah 20 years ago so I'm so
packed up I can't breathe out of my nose
I'm in so much pain stitches in the
stent he does your nose collapse so I
had to put cartilage under here no and I
go well I didn't want I don't want that
because my nose cuz I go is my nose
gonna be better he goes now it'll be go
back to totally normal and I was like
but it's cartilage when you get no
surgery like mine you might hack you I
hope I'll fight that to like put this
mesh thing in scuzz there's all
fractured and then they pack it and they
like leave little stitches but the
packing goes all the way up to here
worse and you're like that for like four
weeks when you go in they take it out
you can breathe there's nothing more
painful but you can breathe well I
didn't care about the pain though I
could breathe the I mean I was like a
frog you know the Frog nostril yeah you
tell me for four for four weeks you
couldn't be that of your no nose huh I
went to that I'm not either
anyway I went to that for five days and
I [ __ ] I thought I was gonna go crazy
you went through that for four weeks I
had to leave it in there yeah then they
had to take it out pull it and you I've
never breathe nobody knows how bad that
is
but I dude when they pulled it out it
was heaven it was disgusting
you don't realize how important
breathing out of your nose is I would
say I can breathe about thirty percent
on my nose so still only there's that
there's a big hard 30 and and to get
like thirties being kind of really yeah
so hit to get it fixed would be my nose
is never clear why don't you go to a
doctor and have them I don't use that
I'm fine I know I'm fine breathe I'm I'm
a mouth breather by nature too I believe
my brother watch my brothers didn't say
Santeria
he's like ones to use is we're all like
that he's got a mouth breather Jesus
wackjob because JJ look over at Jay he's
like Joey Diaz he's on Jay has a resting
smile Jay heads just like and he's got
the Sharpie like this he's like this
chirps hey he's like this I mean he'll
do this he turns his head and mouth
stays so [ __ ] great hmm are we sold
out in San Antonio already oh yeah I
apologize to everybody he's so funny
there is the Figge there he's thinking
by the way he's a think he with the
pharmacy actually he's not now one of
the things I love about I'm kind of
warming to the mask situation because I
look you need to take you take that all
Kat said you look European oh yeah why
then that's all I care about
it looked good or bad I just neck I'm
like well that's the Baggies turtleneck
remember say no because watch this I'm
liking this now cuz it's like is this
cool coming like this that's a good luck
dude with him on my eyes chance why do
you look like you're confused what is my
eyes by the way you know it's gonna
happen my [ __ ] eyes they're gonna
look exactly like it that's like no
different you know he said to me he's
such an awesome doctor he goes he goes
up he goes bro here you're gonna you're
just gonna look less tired dude he
called you bro though no but I don't
want my doctor coming he's a great [ __ ]
yeah I know but don't call me browse my
doctor he feel me he's the guy guy I go
hey do I have States antibiotics they
[ __ ] hurt my stomach he goes they
shouldn't but I mean if you're not
infecting is let me look at your eyes
now you I want my dog to say mr. Schwaab
I don't hey bro no he didn't say bro
okay do papa was in Laguna Beach for a
Father's Day what drove down Saturday
night is a beautiful area
Laguna Niguel I could live there a
little slow but I could live there so
little Republican down there now not a
ton of math you know out of that table
can beat Republican stronghold the beach
and though in the hotel yeah yeah not
many masks either no hey Trump but but
Trump but don't have a rally around
Juneteenth i I got it let me just make
some criticism real cute my family is
that's adorable
well you're cute we are your you
you are we're cute you know you are
you're a great [ __ ] Papa oh yeah
that kid is so the guys are so connected
yeah yeah the way you communicate oh
yeah
it's amazing Brennan calls his son papa
haha but he's we have so much alike
there's nothing he loves more than a
hotel if you if you give him Disneyland
Legoland
Universal or a hotel or pick a hotel
really cuz he knows the hotel you can
play he loves playing with the phones
and calm the front desk Oh like
harassing him and then he loves it's
like a sleepover so he sleeps in the bed
with me
I just he stays up real late so he's
like stay up like nine o'clock I just
told my buddy Brad I go when you come to
LA you stay with me and he's got a lot
of money and he's a grown man
family he goes you say that you stay
with me if you stay anywhere else he
goes hey dude I'll be staying at the
Ritz Carlton I'm not staying in your
funkiness guest room I'll stay at the
Ritz Carlton with a balcony and [ __ ]
breakfast and new fresh ground yeah I
don't need gloves you ain't at my
buddies need your house dude do have a
shower I was on the beach and I told ty
you before we got there I go Papa maybe
the Dolphins that come out for you they
know you're coming they come out for you
you know just some [ __ ] dad things
here the Dolphins came out they they put
on a show they were from me to chip four
of them yeah and that you don't realize
how dark they are I thought they're
always that I thought they're like a
light gray the one sea at SeaWorld not
hands on the golf he's dolphin you know
you might have seen bottled nosed
porpoises they word are they big
dolphins you might have seen bottle
nosed porpoises that's a dolphin because
I know it's a dolphin it's you know
they're all the same family but I think
you may very well have seen they were
like a court opposites they're a dark
puppies you support us porpoises they
were dark grey and Tiger was freaking
out oh yeah maybe they're dolphins if
they are they like these that's exactly
that's exactly what they look like at
4-4 probably four to six of them even
have their cell phones out and my girl
got mad cuz everyone's filming I'm like
Sean tiger and then Boston was yelling
for some reasoning at the dolphins hey
did we talk about how when we were
talking about seals in the ocean a
safety expert who's my friend low key my
one of my best friend's son he's just a
lifeguard but
and then you checked with Kelly Kelly
Slater and calculator goes I thought he
said I think a serious well no not
necessarily
yes yeah yeah the Dolphins are at the
seals around that there can be sharks
but then he said that seals will bite
you
yeah he said Brennan was bitten yeah
hundred times a [ __ ] you up yeah see
line you better be careful man like
they're not there it's not like Oh a
seal no no you get out of the water get
out of the water alright cuz no
territorial the male's
big time and they are terracing their
teeth they're huge cables of the sea the
pit bulls Aussie don't start saying that
through the pit bulls of the sea the
Gymboree up seal ok you don't say that
this two pit bulls of the sake I will
tell you what is a sea all right I'll
tell you what is a co you don't wanna
[ __ ] yeah yeah look at all in if that's
not like oh that's a sharp seal no
they're all like that
they're what neither survive done giant
dog it's a it's it's [ __ ] people of
the sea do well you might want to bring
up leopard seal Oh again that's why I
get brushing one's teeth it's like you
bring up leopard seal there
yeah that's an apex predator on the
shark now so that's a very small one
that's a baby sir don't you bring up how
big they are they all have sharp as
teeth do well the leopard seals
penguins are everybody's terrified of a
leopard seal and you should be a little
bit scared but the guy was scuba diving
with a leopard seal and the leopard seal
kept brick hold on
see lever sealed with a sceptile I there
that looks like my brother that's all my
brother looks at the time my brother
looks like that every greener you know
what my brother he's a lot less my
brother he's the leopards every green
room how's the set there's Jay show
there's Jay
that's so [ __ ] true yeah yeah Sean
the stomach on stage there's Jay right
about that hey I just made six million
dollars there's Jay yeah there's it's
his demeanor never say a thing
wait bring up um so this guy was scuba
diving in a leopard seal
kept killing penguins and bringing them
to him as an offering look at the size
of it please please look at the size of
it you know they're [ __ ] yeah the
huge dude there is killing a plug
[ __ ] penguin but so those dolphins
are right there which in that and tigers
all freaked out and I'm like I told you
do they came out for you so he's all
and everyone's on the beach film it like
this then my girl gets mad like she
thought for who you gonna send that
what do you can do with that footage if
you if you sent me a video like do check
out the like what are you doing dude
yeah what are you doing I don't give a
[ __ ]
well that's nice I was there in person I
was like people taking pictures of
sunsets hey Mike Google sunset and get a
sick Pig that's right there's no
different Mike my girls like whales got
ruined the guy behind us you sit now his
wife and his wife he's laughing what do
you do this footage who he gonna send it
to I go this whole rant and how lame it
is the guy was laughing it's like you're
ruining it I'm like but look at all
these guys any tourist site instead of
just enjoying these dolphins it was on
their phone a posted to the grave okay
go to any [ __ ] tourist site and the
Parthenon
and people are taking pictures of the
Parthenon I told Joanna I went and I
don't have a friend I do not have a
friend who would get their foam out film
this and send it to me well we were
flying over the Grand Canyon there
probably a pilot site boys and gentlemen
that plan of the Grand Canyon's tear
right
oh so many people what do you hey let me
reach over you Oh real quick you just
show me a video of you flying over the
Grand Canyon but the best is when they
go get a little turbulence right now
people they go look to see you to look
at what turbulence looks like well it
looks exactly the same does it yeah you
can't see it si si Senor we all know man
Laguna what some of those fights not the
greatest card of all not the greatest
card of all time
Chris blade you know I got the job done
he's [ __ ] he looks the curved blades
striking looks like he's catching angles
I've never seen him do I think he's
working with Christian Allen yeah cuz he
looks he looks really good and and his
takedowns I think he knew the game plan
against Volkov was to take him down over
and over again which he did he he gassed
a little bit which five rounds fight
that's a lot of bodies let me 18
takedowns idiot I buckle oh yeah not the
best performance like he's not unit on
shot after that no not a chance
I I do think he's he's number four Chris
play for fried win Street he's a he's a
problem for everybody well Francis igano
says hold my face
because he beat him twice I didn't know
that yep so okay um but he's he's a
monster he's right there but you know he
they haven't met three hmm uh him and
Derrick Lewis should definitely fight
during loose as a fight coming up though
hey shot out to Kody Donovan look great
right [ __ ] Cody Donovan is uh I mean
great corner man his fighters are doing
amazing Oh Ohio dudes crushing them in
the number boys are crushing it but yeah
you know yet ste paid Cormier fighting
August 11th so the rubber match Francis
a fight the winner of that then curved
blades probably get one more he wins one
more than um title shot he's one away
from the top shot okay the problem is do
you really let's say Francis beats the
winner of DC steep in right you really
want to see Curtis blades with Francis
three even though he's Owen - I it's
just like it's a it's I tell you why I'm
intrigued by it I I folio a lot of them
has gotten better okay since they last
fought which would be Francis you don't
think cursed place looks a little looked
a little bit different than striking
they look worse hmm yeah you really
knocked out Junior dos Santos yeah but
do you feel gassed in five yeah and you
know in volkov you know dad zero
takedown defense so it's like he
couldn't finish him down there so if I
had to say who since they last fought
who would I put my money in Francis beat
I'm gonna push back because in my
opinion Francis in Ghana has so much
power but if you watch him his actual
when he's the regulars technique of rock
a little bit that's do a little bit you
know why that's it works for him but I'm
saying I don't know that you can say he
got better what you can say is he's
incredibly powerful and he bum-rush them
caught him but I what we go to France
his records rise like ooh Francis beat
since his last fight with yeah yeah
don't hang up so your base it off of the
rosin stroke fight yeah I am you talk
about the twenty second blitz we had no
reason every guy that's silly
well now let me ask you this you like
Cain Velasquez I came back screaming 26
second I like old Cain Velasquez I think
that was a different game well cursed
ladies is good though be in 45 seconds
no no listen
if you he has a nuclear weapon in both
hands if you get caught with huh let me
just go over his last five fights he
beat Curtis blades in 45 seconds he beat
Cain Velasquez in 26 seconds you'd be
Junior dos Santos in a minute
he beat Rosen strike in 20 because you
can't but again when you're that
powerful that fast and that big if I see
your point yeah we don't know yet I'd
like to see him fight steep a again and
see what he looks like baby see they are
neither one's gonna be a great now they
say now DC and you know he's my favorite
heavyweight of all time only because of
his physicality I'm rude cuz I fight a
heavyweight but that's fine I love you I
just I just love these things
okay that's super I was a heavyweight
sled no no I understand that I just
think to me the most impressive
heavyweight at all time is is Daniel
Cormier I'm most impressive yeah because
of because yeah things on stature and
everything and I yeah and so it's my my
favorite - but that's rude I'm still
here I understand I'm sorry that you're
hurting and my eyes are itching like a
[ __ ] game uh-huh I am and did
you throw that to my eyes just now now
now here's the thing about him here's
the thing about Daniel Daniel fought
steep a and just kept walking in and
just we was winning just win and just
back back back he just when he get to
this he's too smart for that
if he does that with an Frances big
trouble oh yeah you don't well it was
steep it you know steep a it's hard but
with Frances like you're knocking like I
won't do that again it's just over yeah
yeah boy boys suck into 205 for Daniel
look at how hollow his eyes are no dude
anybody who says that's that he I used
to always say he'll find it to a 5/5 to
two or five but I mean oh no and he's
one of the greatest heavyweights of all
time at heavyweight why would you fight
you yeah III can't wait County it's real
thick though I can't wait for that uh
that rubber match
I don't this is a hell asleep on steep a
you can see he's one of the greatest of
all time I'd upset DC's dwell time I I
don't want to I personally don't want to
see Steve Bay and and Cormier fight
again for the simple reason that they
especially steeply took so much damage
what's happening I'll just eleventh bro
I know he took so much damage I don't
want to see him take he wasn't speaking
right but he was that friend
knock them out I know and I'd rather let
it let it lie I'll let them bolt you you
rather than both I want Daniel retired
yeah I'm with you too yeah I want Daniel
retired we can't you know they're
fighting so I'm excited for it but I'm
with you I'd rather both him just sail
off to sunset that's how I feel because
I think nothing approved because I think
Francis beats both of them and I don't
want to see steep a take a shitload of
damage to his head even if he wins
against Cormier to the head again and
then fight and then be diminished and
fight and gone oh I'm getting really I
must say this B I think it happened with
JD s happened with Kane it's happening
with Verdoux they're happening with more
cut there's a boy in Makaha you only get
so many hits no matter if you do it all
in that night you know 10 fight streak
you'll get so many hits right so when
when Francis and steep a fought that
first time and I was at the fight
Steve I won that fight he took some all
the power that France had to offer
yeah he beat him yeah and Francis
learned from that fight but steep a got
took some shots I mean crazy you think
about steep a JDS took some shots dude
yeah and steep it Harris fight
Steve face head you could live in his
head he's so big you could I would say I
would say you could put Vic - no no papa
got a head on if Jim put this hat on
which I'm wearing it would look like a
yarmulke what is he able to fit anyway
never fit let me see that happens you
got a big head people I don't have a big
head I have a small head up here fat
face it's not gonna come on that's a
that's a head all right that's a head I
have a giant it's like steep his head if
you haul about would be a modest house
for four
yeah it could house a family Shane's is
a small mansion in the biggest head you
know that's a big head yeah he can't
wait like you there baseball like I
guess you don't get a hat Steven Lucas
is so big when I saw him in person and I
was a bit away from him but he looked so
big he seemed sizes me okay sixty-four
but his head is so much bigger yeah
that's what it is
yes to join it next to Mark Hunt work on
shorter oh God some big but Steven
doesn't get the credit deserves money
someone disgraced American heavy weights
to ever do it South [ __ ] great ass
him being DC there's arguing he's the
best and he saves
Ives dude he look he goes into fire he
saves live visit and he's a blue-collar
guys I'm gonna remodel my kitchen
you [ __ ] cleveland blue-collar stuck
on he's a legend in Cleveland dude he's
thought about steep a he's a legend in
my household you say he should be he's a
legend really close it's nuts
I ran in a Chet Hanks wellheads his rant
no way no way he has all the rapper yes
and and I was at Starbucks getting my
daughter there's [ __ ] mocha
cappuccino and he was there right there
with his girlfriend yeah what the boy
he's such a nice [ __ ] he was he cool
and he knew exactly who I was cuz he
knew because we talked about yeah he
knew exactly what I was a nice cool
balanced a great guy yeah we never say
him bad about him I liked him I said I
celebrate him yeah he's great and and
but he's just a [ __ ] he looks like an
athletic kid by the way he's an athletic
strong he looks strong kid he's a
handsome kid sure he's great handsome
make it easy wrong and very very kind
very nice 59 very humble humble cool
[ __ ] how can you be related to Tom
Hanks and be mean exactly it's got great
parents he's just a good guy he's he's
not he's not Hollywood or anything else
he's just a good five did you get within
six feet of him cuz his Papa had Corona
he shook my hand which I already shared
here take Corona so something to think
about I wear my mask
anytime I'm close to anybody older I
when I'm inside a store I always mask up
cuz I don't want to I don't want to [ __ ]
with anybody older who's afraid
old people are afraid and they should be
yeah they should be and I guess we do
have a real surge we don't we don't know
surgeon cases Sunday was the lowest
death rate we've ever had that's
important i I mean that's very important
yes alright
everyone can freak out do what you want
to do but that's okay what I want yes I
wait we've ever had my chats I sound
like his eyes I like those tight the
skin is tight that's a tight lid I'll
give me that I'm all about tight
sometimes his dad's lids aren't bad
either
his dad probably had my surgery now or
he's probably more secure than me yeah
here's the thing no I'd rather have your
neck than Tom's
yeah I got a good don't say it I have a
good skin on my neck did the earthworm
jim for
though hey earthworm jim earthworm jim
belly belly on your forehead son I did
everything you're not supposed to don't
rub your eyes constantly rubbing them
don't get in the shower
come on let's go oh [ __ ] off you till
you can't shower I mean [ __ ] off [ __ ]
off [ __ ] off gangster
Brian dead seriously text me his the end
of his text but [ __ ] it ride or die
and I went listen he's time I some dead
through something listen don't ever say
ride or die again don't ever take the
ride or die ever again
you but ok ok ok so aggressive hey yo
check Hanks too much yeah dude I run
with a serious crew I'm a fan of his
good guy [ __ ] very pleasantly did you
you very pretty girlfriend how I bet a
sister a sitter dad yes force ya hump ya
know kind of chick in a beautiful
beautiful black woman
Oh gorgeous likes the chocolate yeah
he's she's she's like she's beautiful so
you know she's everybody like listen
he's a good-looking dude - what you've
really good-looking dude what a handsome
kid what's his post on the kid the
Aurore shooter the far left there that
piece of [ __ ] it's a long one slow it
comes in news I don't watch the [ __ ] but
look at this [ __ ] look at the Cureton
the cops take this you okay huh
okay I don't want to take prize but yeah
alright yep you have a fan let's cool
them in if you want to watch something
that's gonna pull at your heartstrings
watch the the documentary dad's on Apple
TV mm-hmm
dude really you want to cry with your
old beaten eyes yeah dude watch that
I've literally felt like I could think
of nothing else that other than my eyes
really sad don't South on Santa yeah
when it gets hot in a room I'm all for
yeah no no no don't put those on yeah
yeah no now you're making fun
of my eyes is that what you gotta watch
dad's I guarantee you well you might not
your sociopath but I guarantee you'd cry
really yeah I'm sure I would dude I'm
sure I watch it yet no one's seen or
nothing like I look at my son some guys
look at my kids tonight I love them so
much I can't take it
oh I can't talk about my family that
crying I know that's what happens
but don't you watch these dads talk
about and what this one dad goes through
I guarantee you if you're a parent you
will cry I can't watch this or or when
Jimmy Kimmel's talking about uh you know
he goes you're only as happy as you how
how healthier kids are and you know his
kid had a health prom do well that's and
he gets choked up oh he's the best dude
I I am it's so good for Father's Day my
it's like 6:30 in the morning 610 oh
you're crying good job with crying dad I
[ __ ] the [ __ ] my daughters downstairs
making daddy-o breakfast and even though
she been went to bed it cuz I let him
stay up watch and you know whatever went
to bed pray but 11 or 12 she's gotta
change to bow to buy it any good
it's a [ __ ] it's a nuclear bomb yeah
there's flour there's chocolate she's
making she's making buttermilk cupcake
sighs she looks on the in line and makes
these yeah but there's no there's not
enough is that aster she's [ __ ]
trying to do it she's it she's killing
it so she's trying to doing her best man
by the way she ended up making me a
great chocolate cake with my effort it
took all day and she killed it my son
made me a he drew this he like drew this
you know he's four so I thought it's a
nightmare so his color it's all over the
place says dad here we heard up there
and then and then he gave me a mug and
he painted it I was like dude was there
any plan of action here or Emmy is just
like every color just like I had my kids
try to paint the picnic table or picnic
table they lost interest the minute they
realized I had the sand
they're like shaky sugar how much longer
I was oh my god you kids the [ __ ]
worse I'm like yeah I did yeah but um
when when dove dove tells a story about
his son his friend
son he goes look at my son look at how
talented he is and and he was like four
and he did a painting or five and he was
look at this he's got like real talent
or six and Duff goes you know the guy's
telling me the kid has talent now if I
took up if I took up [ __ ] goat and I
dip this foot and in a fifth is hoof in
paint and told him to start scratching a
piece of paper off one out it's actually
the same exact [ __ ] things it's true
kids you're blind - yeah well I was and
I was like dude dude was there any was
there any sort of you did you once stay
in the lines at all is there any pattern
or it just like he just was like my son
glasses are fogging up did you crying
with him on high yes people in San
Antonio William Tell Papa I know by that
time I'll be fine mmm well I'm getting
my stitches out they excite for a hotel
Emma I've been talking a big game oh
yeah you know me I know my hotels do
yeah would you for Father's Day kids you
see your papa
I know he's in he's still in Oklahoma so
I called him I never really know what to
do for him he doesn't want anything he
doesn't need anything I stopped sending
gifts a while ago it's like my dad like
what yes every other [ __ ] costume oh
my dad yeah I should call him my dish
wants pictures of my kids well who
invented Father's Day besides a
corporation Elmo make money
same with Valentine's Day hallmark is
genius [ __ ] how do we sell cards
invent Valentines they're good are they
going out of business
hallmark is yeah oh why cause people
using C cards anymore and their movies
aren't doing great either their movies
yeah they have a Hallmark Channel it
began when a young woman wanted to honor
her dad in May 1909 it's an or smart dot
of Spokane Washington shot to Spokane
satin shorts listener Mother's Day
ceremony she decide she wanted designate
a day for her dad William Jackson smart
I sweetness ice
okay so homework they're making up
theirs capitalize on it there's business
business-minded
well that's cool uh celebrate our backs
1860 declared national holiday in 1914
hmm
that's Mother's Day Mother's Day came
first a long time does it make sense
yeah
a sense yeah and that doc they have a
stay-at-home dad and he had no idea what
he's doing
Eames like I'm just gonna document this
and became this huge youtuber oh really
cause you just documented him as a grant
figuring it out and he's good with
cameras and editing and he's like this
huge huge channel now it's him and three
babies he's making back oh yeah but it's
so funny he's like I was terrible at it
it has him on video
kids just like yelling in his hair his
kid going daddy wipe my butt wipe my
butt he's just like stressed the [ __ ]
out
Wow it's great it's so good it's a yeah
it's a great dog that's great yeah right
my body yeah
I love it I love it
anything's a TV show yeah I forget what
it's called anitha
it's a black guy three little boys I
think I think it's two boys and one girl
maybe and he's a huge youtuber now yeah
big youtuber I think it's Tim top right
keep going up and some that's him right
there
so get how cute that kid oh my god holy
[ __ ] that's cute no there there listen
Henry yep being a parents new exec you
my mom's Oh Lord I'm still [ __ ]
learning all of it it's so hard it's so
hard in every way look at that cute
family and you make mistakes with over a
hundred thousand subscribers belief in
father was so good fatherhood yet and
they have Conan O'Brien on there he's
found out he's like yeah like he was you
know back in the day like the dad worked
and the dad was going around on weekends
cuz he's doing all this work he's like
this really talking about it's not like
that that's how most people that I can
to hunt twice really not like that like
the dads like it's not cool to be the
dad who's always gone like that's it's
almost frowned upon now the dad who's
absent it only comes on the weekends or
is only there you know for a short while
and they when the kids come home from
school like that's it's not the way the
father and I I mean oh yeah it was
always the way so I mean for guys my
generation for sure that's that's how I
grew up that's what they're saying that
narrative changing like like especially
meat
being a down i that stay at home with my
two young kids you'd it's such it like
the night that's talking about it he's
like you want to tell it the toughest
job in the world
yeah well you've always said that you
know but but one of the things about
like growing up with the old school
model of nuclear family my mother stayed
at home my father was always gone my
father was always traveling and he was
always gone so and I knew that he was
just working all the time but what
happens is you internalize that that
notion of what it is to be a dad and
what it is to be a provider and all that
stuff so you you know it that's
acceptable to be gone to be working all
the time work first yeah anymore yeah
well yeah I mean if you don't have to do
that if you don't some people have to do
it right but if you don't have to do it
it's it's everything's changing in that
sense everything happen it's also it's
like I'd rather make less money and be
around my kid you'd never need it those
years back men know that's a thing when
your kids like right and when tires for
right now like you're literally forming
your relationship with your son so if
I'm on the road all the time and missed
that those pivotal years it's true but
you know whatever gonna get it back no
it's true but then then you're caught
with that thing of opportunity making a
name for yourself making money see you
maybe you won't be able to make money
later on like I'm good man yeah I'm good
there's nothing there's no amount of
money there's no you spend a lot of time
you you've all all you know you put your
kid to bed every night 100% yeah and
wake up alone every single fight yeah
you do you weigh everything yeah yes
just numero uno in my world I didn't do
that enough but again now yeah now but
remember I put up blaster I have a lot
of regret a lot of a lot of guilt I know
you know I gave just I just didn't know
how to do it but also your dad was
around remember my dad was the Beast
yeah my dad never missed again I love my
dad since no way is this her since pop
water my dad never missed a game Oh see
I played what 14 15 years of football on
the went high school is the game my dad
saw one wrestling match dude never
missed a game never missed a fight flew
to Brazil whoo when I was playing
college football you know we played all
over the nation him and Jay drove or
flew to every single game
but ed never missed a spring game
nothing now he barely comes and he stand
up whatever my special nervous deal and
it's also not something he can he can
kind of participate in they might feel
kind of we can't participate in fighting
it's Nate he's nerve-wracking though my
father always found and watch compared
to fighting what are you [ __ ] me
yeah that's a terrible argument yeah
maybe here we'll argue it yeah but
you're a grown man now so shut up I
didn't get my dad came to one [ __ ]
once point one bleep I knew there's no
talent yeah I remember in fact I took
third in the all New England's whatever
that means about it but I was a high
school is a big deal for man and it was
always lesson there's so many matches
close experiment it was a permanent
tournament at MIT and and it was a like
the culmination of your season it was my
junior year but it was funny about my
father was because his job was so
demanding that he got to see me win the
first two and then he had to leave
because he had to go catch a flight and
so I end up taking third not first cuz
the kid was way better and more
experienced but it's still big I
remember I scored my first touchdown in
peewee football for the Aurora centaurs
shout out to a UIL and Russ brown my
coach I said I was a playing linebacker
and I read the play right and I rat rush
in it was supposed to be a toss and I
intercept it and ran for a touchdown
Wow I look up my it's the only one game
my dad missed my mom was there she's
reading newspaper uh-huh I looked up
she's like this and then junior says my
favorite place I did this like cool
celebration advisor yeah my father
didn't like I had celebration my father
when when I put where I'm running back
with would run and ball in them and just
hand the ball to the ref he goes that's
classy right there don't do all the [ __ ]
don't spike the ball I love the spike oh
it's like the fog advisory make it sack
a dance like [ __ ] junior so you did
oh yeah what was the main position you
played linebacker I don't know why you
didn't play linebacker in college you're
so big Lee I don't know dude
why didn't you I don't know coaches you
know oh they they tell you they they
kind of go
be catching a ball yeah Wow [ __ ] yeah
haters that makes that makes very little
sense to me that's weird enough do you
think that if you had God in the NFL if
you had been groomed as a linebacker you
would have had more lot better chance I
think so I'm more CT though too you know
a lot more CT yeah a lot more CT I don't
think there would have played a lot more
more CT yeah you would have been that's
a you know I had the mean chin were
Thomas and below the belt and it I don't
know how I feel about it he said this
saying you give me your take on this you
know all these guys saying they want
more money all this stuff he says
fighting your si is not a career it's an
opportunity soak that or really
interesting that's a really interesting
thing to say isn't it and I I have to
say I don't entirely disagree
that's what I said I mean if the and
this is with all due respect if my son
comes me and he's really talented
se then he's got all and he says I fight
I want to make a career of fighting I'd
go and he said I wanted on to be MMA I
would say to him are you going to be a
champion and are you gonna hold that
Bell for a long time because that
couldn't be a worse career choice in a
lot of here's the prom B's I went on
this whole rant on how you should look
at odds when you're making a career
decision I understand look I was an
actor we may be correct you still are
mhm
you know you didn't know I mean yeah
that's yeah so I'm gonna duck I'm gonna
dice this good couple of your lids don't
pop you're not gonna but you you can't
look at odds anything so if your son
comes you and goes dad I want to be in
the UFC and go if do you want to hold
the bell he goes oh no I don't be that
good then he shouldn't do it right any I
guarantee you I will get everybody any
fights gonna ever talk everybody wants
pitch and he talked to me when I first
got to UC they said what's the goal the
battle champion now
every single person I'm you saw last
Saturday night fight every single person
ability in career
oh [ __ ] a career every single person
believes on that cards in the next
economy it's the only way you're even
gonna get to the day it gets you through
training it gets you through competition
to get you give you tour every moments
yeah I agree you can't step on anybody's
dreams you can't in dreams are
irrational and dreams should be
irrational a lot of times you you will
feel like so many people I say what do
you want like I said what you want what
would you ask for if you knew you
couldn't be refused
it's a really important question because
it forces you to face up to act what you
really want but most of us don't say
that to ourselves because it there's no
way right
it sounds irrational but most dreams are
not rational most dreams are pretty
crazy kill honestly when you say look at
odds the reason I get so excited when
you come off and crush after you know
and when we're on the road when you tell
me you want to be a stand-up I was very
worked oh yeah I mean I was we should
and then frankly tell me you want to be
a stand-up I said this is a disaster
yeah and I tried to kind of talk you out
and I know and you do a joke about it
because what happened my voice got
really hives I know yeah oh oh you know
I said when he said I want to be a
stand-up because he was hard for him to
admit it I went oh yeah oh ok ok
that's all I could say because I didn't
I didn't know he always knew he's funny
but I this is a very difficult gig yeah
but imagine imagine if I listen to
everybody well I mean but that's my
honey but it's a good message to [ __ ]
it's my same Minister for people that
read comments online why would you give
any of those people validation on
anything look because if you listen to
any of that you're never gonna do
anything yeah because they're because
they didn't chase any of their dreams
and that's what that's where the hate
and the regret comes from in the hate
that someone who's living their dream
that's where they out they they go Adam
they lash out at buddies it's it's hard
you don't listen your friends you listen
your family especially your friends and
family actually I would say especially
online any person you admire any person
might never listen to comets or what
family or friends said because anyone
with a rational brain would go no you
can't do that yeah because that's your
parents your own parents my own an
acting teacher used to say don't go home
for the holidays because your parents
and your siblings are gonna talk you out
of your dream and they're gonna talk you
out of your dream because they love you
and they're worried about you
and I'll tell and I'll tell you this
yeah her family friends or online can
talk you out of your dream then you
shouldn't be doing it yeah there's not a
person on this earth who talked me out
doing anything I want to do they don't
exist whether it was you rogon my dad
Jay there's not a person that yeah if I
want to do something I'm gonna do you'll
do what I say you'll do what a sad
I'm in dr. pay then he's not gonna knock
Shane your boss you're not gonna die you
but not my boss do it a saying bud and I
got a flat hand that says yes and I got
a flat hand it says even harder yes all
right good news and bags I like that
hold on I've good news in bed but rain
good news is not take the wisdom I just
dropped yeah the bad news is boss I'm
gonna take 60/40 now you're not boss
boss boss right but my hand is heavy my
hand is swollen on your right on let me
call the boss and see what he says about
the merge split hold on
yeah is this Brendan I know this is him
hey you want to do 80/20 listen dude he
need now KITT no I talked about they
wanna do any 20 but I'm not gonna do
though that that but dude you know what
I might do this weekend
all [ __ ] aside cuz my house would be
better I might slap you in the [ __ ]
knife oh my god and your eyes better be
better cuz Malik keeps saying it's
Russell Friday
I'll buy Malik Malik you're Malik Malik
Malik [ __ ] sake you're the worst at
names the worst [ __ ] mouth I admit
it's worst of all time Malik you've
called me Brandon so we're even
here's the thing if you know they don't
know anymore here's the thing if you
wrestle me I'll be tried it easy
if you wrestle me on Friday Malik if you
aim at Malik Malik metallic like it's
Alex Mallin
metallic Malik yeah metallic Malik
listen if you rub something out Friday
I'm gonna take you on your old friend
here but he just got his eyes done [ __ ]
you Douglas head surgery Malik if you
rub some on Friday I'm gonna [ __ ] your
old friend up here you know you tell me
yeah the doctor said hey listen I can
tell you're the kind of guy that's gonna
be like yeah whatever and you're gonna
start doing [ __ ] and go blind he goes
yeah he goes now sometimes what happens
is guys like you go out and say you know
what I'm gonna clean my hubcaps and then
I'm gonna clean my car maybe I'll wax it
too and what happens is you can get your
eye to go bruised like that and blow the
[ __ ] out I would love and then you can
go blind there like one of those girls
don't [ __ ] around you know what you look
like right now
you know those goldfish with those nut
ice bring up those goldfish tray that's
what you look a little dizzy right now
you look what I had something to say
about um slap
around Oh me being your boss I remember
my buddy Jimmy Burke it's hot story well
that's not look like I'm sweating I'm
sweating in hits hi please don't beat me
up right now okay but um my buddy my
buddy Jimmy Burke Terry Jerry's your
size and and not weak and very strong
when he was younger he was a bear and
Jimmy's built like me and Jerry we were
talking and drinking at his house
[ __ ] around and Jerry started talking
Jimmy goes ah shut up and slapped really
hard and Jerry goes boom like that and
you see him and Jerry and Jerry and I
said shut up
BAM and whacks him again and Jerry
remember in the cartoons when the
gorilla is gonna take your pull your arm
yeah he goes like that
Jerry head go down and Jimmy read it his
primordial brain goes I have to run he
runs and as he runs into the other room
Jerry is gonna close in and kill him and
Jimmy's completely naked as we we always
got his he's got a starfish pointed
right at the door ass on the bed plastic
possum naked possum it's called naked
possum it's called the naked bottle
Jerry sobered up meeting us he goes ah
[ __ ] kryptonite policy genius.com yeah a
few questions about yourself and your
property then positives we'll compare
compare your policy against options from
top insurance to make sure you're
getting the right home insurance covers
are the best possible price it's about
competition just and they will help you
do that I'm sweating it finds you a
better rate you want a car to pass use
it will compare your home and auto
passes across different insurers and
even mix and match to find you savings
they saved their customers an average of
one thousand two hundred and one
thousand one hundred and twenty seven
dollars per year just doing that that's
insane so if you like cash back in your
pocket right now see how much you can
save by reshaping your home insurance
rates that policy genius.com I just did
it you guys should do it great grand
great all you got to do is go to policy
genius.com answer a few quick questions
about yourself and your property and
Booya you're saving money policy genius
calm this episode of fire kid is brought
to buy the one the only the best workout
device ever I'm talking about whoo baby
I'm rocking it I told Brian said take a
hike you went I'm tired I forgot to wear
mine I said then you're not in this ad
dude I'm gonna take it from here
listen big boy by club Dickies we've all
been on the stationary bike like man it
says I'm burning 1,400 calories so I'm
like Jimmie Johnson NASCAR how many
calories am i burning well guess what
take the guesswork out of it whether
it's a stationary bike a regular bike a
run a workout playing basketball
whatever it is track your workout to the
exactiy how much you're burning how much
rest Ergon what's your output I'm
talking about whoop-whoop is a
membership service that provides fitness
tracker for free and gives the members
access to their app which provides
personalized insight into recovery
strain and sleep recovery so when you go
hard in the paint how much sleep I can
how much recovery again should you go
hard
should you rest should you take your
time off it tracks it to a freaking tee
using your heart rate loop tracks
everything man from your recovery are
you ready to go should you go hard in
the paint should you rest your strain it
goes beyond track and just steps and
focus on something meaningful strings
this is looking at for how active your
heart is throughout the day and
calculates that intense house-trained us
your days through daily exertion on your
workout based on your recovery whoomp
provides target strain goals which helps
leads to more optimal training so maybe
you can go further in your mouths maybe
you can run further maybe you shouldn't
run as far we need to know what you're
doing man whoomp also tracks your sleep
your sleep cycle your stages
disturbances your efficiency I think I'm
getting eight hours I wore my whoop that
went actually in for homeboy so yeah
step your game up man whoop has a strap
3.0 has a five-day battery life on the
go charging so you never need to take
off I wear mine in the shower they're
waterproof I wear it swimming my son I
see how many calories I'm burning the
loop strap 3.0 can connect to a
Bluetooth Low Energy device so you can
sync your heart rate to compatible
treadmills bikes rowers I just have it
on my phone it's so dang easy man and
you guys get 15% off when you go to
whoop calm that's wh ooo P calm enter
the code fighter at checkout to save 15%
off sleep better recover faster train
smarter optimize your performance with
whoop and
it's very rare I reach out to a sponsor
to be jump on the train but with
everything I'm doing with my think boy
bike club and my workouts I was sick of
just guessing what exactly my workouts
were burning calories and if I'm getting
enough sleep so I reached out to whoop
here we are go to whoop calm 50% off use
the coach fighter again let's go to
whoop calm promo code fighter save 50%
off see better recover faster train
smarter write harder ride thick whoop
calm Bobby can you tell I'm excited
about Texas Lone Star didn't even see us
Rangers woah dude looking at property on
Friday Wow I'm with you I'm gonna check
it out
are you yeah I keep thinking AHA I don't
I don't leave the old man behind don't
put me in a Texas corner and make me bit
by my way up don't pick don't pay taxes
corner nope okay see what happens let's
see what happens if you want to
devastate the fans in Texas and and
firing the kids I live in Skid Row I I
don't really appreciate being home with
my kids in here ah [ __ ] I just like
people who have mental illness and then
need help I mean I need you to go but in
treatment I need and I don't know if
this helps persuade you you can live on
our property thank you well if you live
in taxes full house you live in the pool
house no I have live in my pool I got my
money [ __ ] off okay shut up
I can't I'm gonna do that this weekend
now tell you guys I hurt your eyes I'm
gonna do it like it now um this this but
I'm thinking um if you have an animal I
guess on your property if their house
it's an agro cracks credit so you even
get more money back from the state
already looked at it Papa's gonna have a
sheep and a horse are you
yep issues I'd love sheep don't need
horses too big I'd like some goats
I'd like some chickens you know I'd like
one baby cow as my friend had a baby cow
so today grow up to be big cows see but
I want that I'll tell you what I can't
eat it no one's gonna kill them
yeah I'm gonna squirt the milk into my
mind
I'm gonna I'm gonna you know do this a
lot I'm gonna slap him around squeezes
knows my kids are gonna ride them well
I'm gonna be Ralph yeah if it's a cow
it's his name
cows are female so it's not gonna be a
male oh no I just say Ralph I met Ralph
uh well Ralph Ralph inna afina
oh dude oh my god I'm [ __ ] with you
dude I oh my god I'm [ __ ] with you
dude I'm gonna get a long horn in Texas
bar I'm gonna a giant my safe around
kids now here's the thing security yeah
the goats up on the property but my boy
over here Bruce yeah I'll [ __ ] you up
now well there's stories about fighting
bulls in Spain that cut out and got into
houses and killed people in their own
houses see I don't want that really
bring up Madeira fighting ball
oh yeah that's brutal dude take a look
at these another fire no that's brutal
though you're not allowed to approach
them on foot on foot in Spain by law
because otherwise you will get chin do
me of I don't like seeing that do me a
favor I don't want to see it speaking of
cookies and animals yeah I can't I don't
think I'm gonna eat pig anymore I just
read all the pigs are so smart smartened
dog but they're also like they have the
cognitive cognition of a three-year-old
human [ __ ] I don't think I can do it
no I read that I was like I like a pork
I love I live work I live before I don't
I hate pork but the way they keep them
in these crates I don't think I can do
it I like ribs now it's a wild risk if
it's a wild pig think I promise I'm a
boars we're gonna shut those down and I
gotta shut them down um chin see how
much of Texas Longhorn cost to buy
that's gonna be my security guard my
kids are gonna grow up with it okay
we're gonna we're gonna file down this
warrants and he's gonna be head of
security it seems gonna be Bruce Bruce
yeah statue sighs that bull I'm [ __ ]
around balls dude mmm how much is a
miniature long one okay really mad okay
see that big one on the right that's
what I'm looking for but he's too old
not for sale it says not for 2,500 look
at the little bull now you get yourself
a bull for 25 I'm in so uh what all
pointing oh my god Esmond bell
point Hey ooh let me see boot it up down
below there boot it up 50 200 see I like
little heifer dough tada
I like the the cut-and-dried heifer for
1,700 that's now it says cut and dried
heifer yeah that's the deal flower patch
I'm cutting drives name's gonna be
Brucie we're calm a little bruised cutie
pie any cute so I'm gonna move to Texas
I'm gonna buy little Bruce I'm jealous
now what I want to know is the
maintenance on those things it's price
maintenance I know
gotta have it you got to have a cowhand
about and this is why I want you Kim
Texas where you watch my Mike longer I'm
a man I'm a man I'm a man among I'll pay
you I'm a beast master yes take care of
my long boy yeah like on will get tough
checks whoa cowboy tough checks get
dirty dancer 3,300 what do you come Jack
Hobbs records off Jack's isn't for sale
he's my boy black hot red cone is though
or door jam 3200 damn what are dragging
blaze drag on y'all a drag Ella
oh my god dragon smile Dropbox dude look
at the possibilities how about I get a
nice drop the ACE with a easy whip five
grand I get my security I like that they
were feeling froggy by Olga foe of goth
oh well I'd like I'm gonna get myself no
cows no horses I'm gonna get myself some
goats I'll get myself some chickens a
little couple Oh
I'm absent I some dogs chickens not some
dogs that keep the goats or the Sheep
yeah you know karate I look at this
property three acres your [ __ ]
animals roam around kids away full okay
I'm accepting ball need to come papa
Oh God I need you come come I'm coming
I'll be there no state tax Jesus Christ
save some Monay
save some when you stand up out there do
the road Lelia chin foaming-at-the-mouth
didn't want to come look at cat
you both come I'm from Texas so that's
why I have like a love for Texas boy
that's a big move that's a tough one
yeah but you consider it for sure cat
I'm thinking about it but I'm leaning
more toward
yeah but they're gonna say no like no I
quit today
bye guys look at that whole time talk to
the father-in-law father-in-law my
grandpa yeah mother oh so down
it was excited it's pretty good Davis
let's see we can stay here and have
govern Newsom be your daddy
and taxes going on this one
why taxes don't help all myself mmm no
I'm just
could you take Adam and do something I
just wanted to be oh I know yeah so um
oh yeah I talked I got I got hit by some
cops about oh I got one for you why you
don't get hit it wait huh MA I got an
email for the cop I know you got you
okay oh yeah yeah this this is from a
cop don't give us a name don't go so
this guy goes hey dummies I put that in
there but I just wanted to try explain
why cops don't shoot for the legs morons
in a response to Brian askin on the
podcast
I am law enforcement officer and
ex-military there are two main reasons
why this isn't a practical solution the
first is difficulty yes I want you to
think about when you two are at the
range imagine trying to hit a nice sized
target at 7 to 10 meters that's not when
your life's in danger that's not easy
shot to begin with then imagine trying
to do it on a moving target now Jack
your heart rate up he'll hunt 180 and
try it it's almost impossible add to the
fact that law enforcement uses Glocks
with an 8 pound trigger and iron sights
I am on a unit that trains a lot and
this is still almost impossible never
mind a regular beat cop who shoots 100
rounds a year this why we aim at center
mass the other reason dum-dums is every
time you discharge your firearm at a
subject you have to be justified to use
lethal force no matter where you end up
hanging them if you hit the femoral
femoral artery emeral are don't bleed
out and set around you made it as well
hit them in the chest plenty of people
have died with leg shots yeah hope this
reaches you and helps dumbasses
he wasn't saying dumbass that was
Brennan because we deserve that feel
free also Joanie you mean also when you
shoot for the legs
a police officer is responsible for
every round that goes off so that was
the answer to my question I knew it
probably something like that hi you
didn't a lot of guys reached out and
some guys were who lit
really are the ones who are responsible
for the for all of this I mean they have
to come up with answers so we appreciate
it guys
so yeah very tough situation very tough
dummies I will also say that
Rashard Brooks I'm gonna get [ __ ] for
this but he didn't he did in in Georgia
shooting a Taser an officer is
considered lethal lethal force an
attempted lethal force because you
render the officer take his gun so they
are trained I'm just saying what they
are trained for okay so if you have a
problem the training talked to them yeah
but that officer was trained clear and
as day to do exactly what he did
interesting and it was and if you watch
it I wasn't there
these speeds and everything that went on
the other thing that I'm gonna say which
is kind of crazy is but I always wonder
about this is that his if you look at
racial books rap sheet there is a charge
that says cruelty to children and I
wonder sometimes as a human being if
that changed that changed the police
officers mindset it was you know I
always think about it look it up and say
I think they look now what happens is
now they go this you know then now it it
kind of creates another rival and my
mind goes piece of [ __ ] a lot of people
do and that's and that's so so so so we
have to keep these are so many factors
that will come out in court of course
and we'll see it but I just think it's
very important with all these things in
perspective say the other thing is
chocolate Willick who was saying unless
you trained for this [ __ ] the reason
what we look at Special Forces guys
likes Navy SEAL SEAL Team six a Delta
Force the reason they're so good and the
reason that they is because they never
stopped training because they trained
with with without constant counselors in
in real-time or they're getting shot by
like wax bullets and all kinds of [ __ ]
so I gotta make a phone call
yeah but also don't ever say Schumann
the legs again it's do some current
events what do we got control its Trump
in a box so a lot of people were posting
up videos and photos of the Trump rally
in Tulsa and people were speculating
that something weird was going on
because there wasn't a large turnout and
what ended up happening was they
apparently the people who claim to be
behind the reason why there was such a
low turnout
happens to be teenagers on tik-tok and
k-pop fans again they went and they
registered a bunch of seats for this
yeah for this event and they ended up
not showing up so when you got there
there were a couple thousand people and
I think a 20,000 people venue so it
looked super empty they thought it was
gonna be so packed that they were
planning to have Trump give the speech
again outside to people who couldn't get
into the stadium but they ended up
canceling that as well yeah I mean there
were 6,200 people six 300 people out of
twenty thousand seat arena you said just
past eight hundred thousand tickets
biggest data hole and rally signup of
all time by 10 times Saturday is gonna
be amazing Trump's biggest [ __ ]
liability and the reason that he sucks
and regardless of look he did a great
job of the economy it's all good but but
the reason he sucks is because this
[ __ ] guy is more concerned with being
popular and and this is this is cute
you're like kind of like I'm Paul
accordingly
I'm Amanda I think that's called
footsies oh yeah this [ __ ] guy is
more concerned with a photo-op and a
[ __ ] rally and it's just he's the
last thing he's not a unifier let's put
a power but then again our nation has
always been pretty [ __ ] divided maybe
that's it we can't vote for Biden I I
can't vote for that your old friend I
can't vote for Trump
I might not vote is there a third option
when I came out no vote yes to vote for
Trump is that true yep that's a big this
is this is the problem with our [ __ ]
just maybe the system he just made that
no but I've have heard that if you don't
vote it's basically a vote for Trump um
I don't know if I read that I lean more
right economically I lean more right in
a lot of philosophical ways I'm socially
very liberal I don't know have no men
speaking of Mickey Mouse don't like
camel hair though Disneyland is set to
open July 17th now
Pacific reservations hold on on the
train yeah it's important no no I want
to say say I said this before but listen
it's important it's is important I know
you're right you [ __ ]
is our country so I'm left with this so
there's a huge movement where where
black lives matter where there's a
itself there's an idea that we're black
like we have to really worry about you
know Latin what you really think about
is not racism it's about the black vote
and and their their political influence
that's how you make change okay but it's
very interesting that every [ __ ]
democratic every Democratic candidate
Connell Harris and all these [ __ ]
[ __ ] including button want to
decriminalize the border okay
so then when when in five years when the
Hispanic vote renders the black vote
completely irrelevant you tell me that
black lives matter then because they're
gonna have zero political power and they
may it's not may as well not even
[ __ ] vote because the truth is and in
in local politics and local elections
and districts that's what the [ __ ]
matters when you talk about change
so people who sit there and say we that
we want to decriminalize the border
Trump's an [ __ ] building the wall
youto you're a snake eating its own tail
you make up your [ __ ] mind
daddy daddy you're a little hot well
your stitches and my stitches ready your
stitches fallen I don't like
inconsistency and over debt in what's
politics so that's all politics so but
be philosophically consistent be aware
that one choice you take is gonna affect
another chore instant you [ __ ] die
your stitches falling out sorry I'm
sorry cat worried no let's get some
party shoes get now some that's really
in effect you don't play with my foot
sorry daddy Disneyland yeah July 17th
yeah I heard they're gonna open up July
17 but how's that work you're gonna have
to buy tickets ahead of time and have a
reservation so they cap it and if you
have a season pass I think you would
then have to still sign up for a certain
day that you may less crowd or the canno
could be you know what a few ones have
to be a math but they're at during
Orange County an Himes Orange County
which is more Republican a little less
laid-back mmm-hmm we'll see either way
good news yeah I'm wait for Legoland to
surprise luckily it's not open that's in
San Diego
yep I've never been seen who has six
confirmed deaths Acronis entire time
goddamn that's hit six more people have
died of [ __ ] stinking stuff in there
but yeah I mean it's a weird example I
mean it's so absolutely my daughter what
the [ __ ] we go boogie-boarding
somebody mentioned
stingrays somebody mentioned getting
stung by stingray let me now my daughter
every time we go she goes I just saw
three stingrays Oh like you didn't see
any stingrays yeah said I came really
cuz one came down and kind of brushed my
foot I'm like this is all in your mind
nobody this is what happened yeah so the
fear worse than the [ __ ] let's get
news about Disneyland though that's good
news let's get back to Disneyland so
there is a petition out right now where
people want to change the name Columbus
from the city Columbus Ohio to
flavortown
I'm all for after Guy Fieri because he
is a Columbus Ohio native and people
don't want the city to be named after
Christopher Columbus anymore
Oh who's Christopher Columbus was a guy
who did use apparently and I remember
reading about this in high school when
in 1984 he did use smallpox Laden
blankets and gave them to the Native
Americans on purpose pretty he was not a
very he wasn't paying a good man
nobody was not racist back then sure
especially Europeans nobody was human
beings slavery was was everywhere was
everywhere in the world so if you want
to judge everybody in the in history
take down all this no we have to get rid
of all the museum's
all the museum's honey and get rid of
all the art yep that every artist is
done because Leonardo da Vinci and
[ __ ] Michelangelo I promise you
painted the Sistine Chapel probably
weren't as politically correct as the
whoa crowd either no so again this is
where the far-left becomes crazy if I
were black I never was comfortable with
statues of robert e lee i was personally
never comfortable with [ __ ] the
confederate flag i just never was I'm
much older than everybody this debates
been raising for way longer than a lot
of people have been alive and the
question becomes do we preserve our
country's history even if it's blighted
history we're not going to take slavery
and the story of slavery out of history
books we need to know and face it it's
very important the same way some of
those symbols might represent a
checkered history a bad part of our
history I understand though I understand
hey listen this is the debate do we do
have to call flavortown though can we
call it like die fury town here's the
thing
to rep a flavortown Jersey I don't care
what type of team it is Jesse that says
Columbus was blue jackets the NHL
Dingles yeah
Cincinnati Oh daddy fresh on flavor town
Bengals have a town I don't know let's
go though and they say he's a great guy
he always gives back he's a great guy
all right so don't dye your hair like
that not because he's a great you don't
die your beard like that and not be a
great guy we should get got a [ __ ]
vodka take us flavortown
I take us a flavor daddy tell fury taste
he took us five over town it's loans is
it flavor it was good
any rides with dr. pepper he's proud of
he's he's very confident with food he
look at you go put that in your mouth
check that out
try that tell me what happens I don't
ever eat I'm did I go are we going to
flavortown is this a one-way ticket of
flavor say baby ba thanks guy
yeah I think he's got some moaning - oh
I don't know I don't think he flies at
market captain of flavortown you kidding
me yeah he's doing you take us the
flavor baby what else you got
your boy I don't know if you guys know I
deal hubely in person comes from Cova
times yeah I see him all the time when
we on I Drive to work down the 101 he
drives a convertible Bentley he's one of
my favorite comedians I love it gonna
collapse
damn bro any but he said it was cuz it
Kovac no well so he it was exhaustion
and dehydration but let me tested him he
also had Cova 19 yet the problem huh
exhaustion dehydration flying up all
night but then he had Kovac I would
assume he passed out from exhaustion
where was no one pass out cuz it opens a
knees and now examines has to close
because of the Cova 19 no not forever
they had better just because there's yes
was he tested positive I'll just show
the video if seems like dizzy I mean I
don't want to I love deal he does he
drink like dizzy yeah so I think
something has to do drinking is a
lawman's by watching it
yeah the main security guard about
missing one front takes him away
jill has style - men good-looking dude
maybe four days along them and we came
back lured a memory I want to get rid of
it
thanks kittens to call they were
immigrants
so let's ice dozing off right there yeah
I think it's buddy or security I grabs
him and then I think he's just passes
here
don't follow the stool like that
he might have been might have been
exhausted drinking whatever was but also
had killed it you know yeah yeah poor
deal that sucks
you never want that to happen he came
out afterwards and made this statement
he sounds pretty lucid and clear here
he's good suffering from exhaustion
after all weeks working travellers kept
overnight at the hospital for tests
under doctor's orders
he's awake and feeling better which
thank you run there you go yeah
I almost passed out in Denver forgot I
was a mile up I'm jumping around kicking
the [ __ ] and I had to stop and I go I'm
dizzy
and they all start laughing cause her
life I hope you [ __ ] I loved you and
that's what I saw what scene he's he's
amazing all right well speedy recovery
yeah hopefully zannies opens up soon I
mean I'm there November she very um all
right this isn't fascinating you guys
used that loop watching and different
kind of watches to test your heart rate
and all that stuff so Jimmy Johnson war
watch during a race and check that out
that's how much oh my god yeah that's
how much you're actually stressed out
during the race
it says it was an average of 100 and was
it at 149 beats per minute that's Oh God
so that's his heart rate yeah you spent
over 2,500 calories doing a three and a
half hour long race just show you to
show you how intense those driving
sessions I'm not I'm not disagreeing now
if you wrote a bike for three and a half
hours you can burn way more time Samson
if you rollerblade for three and a half
hours huh you can burn way more Cup huh
if you skateboard for three and a half
hours you're gonna burn a shitload what
about your heart rate if you bike your
heart rate spray that will your if you
bike if your mountain biking was three
half hours you can burn your heart
racing me probably similar maybe not the
highest out how you maintained a see
this point uh I don't know probably I
don't know I'm just saying like that to
me that's like okay Oh your heart rates
up like physical right you're using your
whole body in a way you actually are
using your whole body you're you're
reading space you action time yeah and
I'm probably I mean you times I'm just
saying to me but you're not mad if you
call it a sport I don't care I literally
don't care but people have these debates
I know but if you call sport
cool yeah that's what you don't go
I don't know but it's like if you surf
for 39 hours you'll earn more calories
if you took a nice jog for 3/9 hours
you'd burn more calories the better with
a better question rather than saying
it's a sport the better thing is this is
Jimmy Johnson athlete
that's been the question meaning like a
lot of times we see a guy that doesn't
work but it does because it doesn't
because he's John Daly an athlete I
think he is the big fat John Daly I
think John Daly would probably be good
at throwing a baseball I think you're
wrong I think you're dead wrong why I
mean you ever seen Connor McGregor throw
baseball or football he's an athlete I
know so it doesn't but someone like John
Daly was a big like that I would imagine
I wouldn't be spent here looks like he
could be a pitcher if he wasn't that
happy I think that they are get to say
yeah I think it's insane to say you
don't know I hope I mean I have an idea
it's well because pitching is a skill
but it's a very specific skill there's
many not off mm-hm
there's many people they can pick up a
baseball you'll have to tell me and
throw that ball cuz they're athletes I
can give Mark Sanchez out there a
basketball you can't dunk it I'll have
to show him how to dunk it well being
announcer then G like I'm asking you is
Jimmy Johnson I don't know I have no
idea I've only know what I'm saying the
average NASCAR guy honest I have no idea
but my question for you if you want to
see because he's good athlete there's a
sport is John Daly an athlete well that
without Tiger Woods it no but that's a
good question because what I'm saying is
that our athlete I would say who that
yeah I would you know there's so much
you can Bowl so here's what I mean
the average NBA player the average NFL
player is an athlete in terms of you can
they can do a lot of sports I feel hold
on every personally in a filth an
athlete thank you because they carry
golfers an athlete not every NASCAR
thats what I'm asking so that's like I
say that's the question I'm not
disagreeing with you I'm saying that's
the question ask so so in my case if you
see if you see the anybody who plays in
the NBA I I believe is going to have
better coordination speed power
strengthen as an athlete is an
all-around athlete it requires physical
dexterity that is off the charts no one
on the planets gonna say otherwise
that's the term you may be able to what
I'm saying is that I don't know you can
say that about every very good nice card
I don't know you can say about every I
think every case my case yeah the fun
that was my point like tight routes
predict is the guarantee and give Tigers
the baseball you throw a baseball not
100 miles an hour he's not gonna like
ridiculous doing it you give John Daly a
baseball or football might look a little
ridiculous he's never thrown one so I
don't know but yeah I'm sure there's
bring John Daly up naked no now Jimmie
Johnson and then there's Bubba Wallace
you know there's some guys through
pretty athletic if I can handsome older
he could give a [ __ ] John Daly is John
does John he looks like Joey beers and
white face there's no idea they were
saying they were saying about they were
saying about John Daly and they were
like he said Tigers come hang out with
us practice he goes [ __ ] practice cuz
you could say that John you're really
talented I'm not as talented as you are
he could give two [ __ ] huh well they
are the same person
it fit John Daly encouraged that's his
son vodka yeah to get rid of his son
could give two [ __ ] these great guys
are hilarious by baby does it all huh
John deal he smokes drink apples just
look nice
yes just a [ __ ] me this looks like
Joey Diaz dude he really does he could
give a [ __ ] yeah I don't
yeah I'm again I I've never driven
NASCAR I'm sure it's very challenging
I'm sure there's some good athletes but
I don't know great pants he's a colorful
character
he's Oh everyone with yummy Oh My Jesus
I mean the biggest kind of we oh my lord
he's big
I can't believe still alive I'd be
honest yeah he's eight foot though Jesus
yep it's got one more it's a good one
see just to your argument to be not
every UFC fighters a good athlete I
don't know if that's true who would you
know why that would I who would you say
yeah I see we don't know but I mean be
able to throw a punch I mean to wrestle
not everyone know you think every I just
think it's such an athletic event I
think it's such a the wrestle kick punch
is so F it's like
hard to do well we can learn it you
don't have to have the talent to be able
to wrestle or do jujitsu or box
now there's ones that learn it and have
talent like John Jones Conor McGregor
who are athletes
like a guy like DC but no matter how
much I practice don't a baseball or
football if I don't have the talent or
athleticism it doesn't matter I can get
good at Rus and not be that up yeah
that's true and you can get yeah you can
knock somebody out and not be yeah
fighting a skill it's a lot of skill
I've got up ton of skill yeah yeah it's
interesting it's the weird argument
though you know it is and we all the
great athletes are not going into UFC
this is not enough money they're great
get some great athletes like Conor
McGregor or George st. Pierre could be
you know yeah now what's Kabir's
vertical what's kibby's forty times uh
it's not what you not it's not Oh what's
a five five Brian you'd run a five flat
in the fort I believe that his verticals
by 24 he's just been wrestling his whole
life but that's like lawyer Paul I
learned that but not like thoughts could
be but football he's probably gonna have
a tough time making the NFL team as well
it's just that I'm just saying it's I
think he's gonna go to the combines but
he's gonna have a hard time deciding the
ball it's just a weird argue like it's
tough like you look you're like marathon
runners ultimate like campaigns
yeah monster dude [ __ ] monster yeah
but I don't know as forty is right
that's deep through a combine I don't
think is right it's an interesting
expression yes yeah and here's my thing
I don't care
hey NASCAR called sports and I don't do
air I don't give a [ __ ] yeah I'm not the
gatekeeper who's the sports who's not
mmm
go ahead yeah you guys are athletes I
don't care yeah but that but that thing
to me isn't that impressive
twenty-five more collagen three half
hours I think what's what's interesting
about that is I didn't think they would
even be burning that much or even be
like their heart wave would beat up that
high for a heart rate makes sense
because you know you're the drill and
stuff like that but you only five names
let me do for two and out three and a
half hours
twenty-five hundred you got a hike on
Runyon up and down fifteen half hours
your burn way more than but that you can
visualize you can see why there's
exertion but with you were you driving a
car it just feels like you wouldn't be
exerting that much but you
really you were there it's nuts yep yeah
but even you now you're burning calories
Jen yeah you probably there's no way
it's like that though
well I'm just saying pride burn 400
calories I have no idea who no I don't
think 400 I don't know all right last
one yeah
cats cousin actually made the news hey
for one week I'm just kidding Schneider
cuz she's ready miss hook that's racist
sorry sister agent lady cards we have
fun that's probably why I thought Laney
college this girl her name it's fukui
and then her teacher actually told her
to change her name and this this is the
email what you can't do that see that
name English sounds like [ __ ] Vietnam in
my name in your language sad like eat a
dick I would change to avoid
embarrassment both on my part and the
part of the people had to say understand
you are offended but you need to
understand your name is offensive sound
in my language I repeat my request Matt
hey Matt hey Matt you're saying well I'm
sure they fired him yeah he was on me I
don't they fired him yes what is he is
he a teacher yeah he's a professor
what the [ __ ] are you saying but also
Matt a little more professional
it's the flat a friend named eat dead I
mean Jesus Christ hey Matt hey look at
me
we gotta let you go or her name is Fukui
yeah foot boy it's not for fuk boi jesus
christ we're gonna call you [ __ ] boy but
he's awesome I mean I mean but also be a
little sensitive [ __ ]
Jesus good anyway he was he was trying
to be helpful
of course he wasn't though you should be
I don't know what he was trying to being
a dick incredibly loud a friend named
eat dick Jesus Christ Jesus yeah that's
I understand her usually people I feel
are very sensitive I understand that and
that was submitted by daily I'm sorry
guys I'm feeling belly fat that's funny
how do you say that name do you know boy
this foot boy look complete so it does
sound like it [ __ ] boy but there are
worse names Laius there's a female name
that spelled bi CH and it's pronounced
but big but it looks like [ __ ] yeah
well you dad dad I understand changing
name because it's very hard to for
people who don't speak Vietnamese to be
like how do I say your name I mean
you're gonna get you're gonna get
roasted but yeah
of points you like you're not saying
that someone's first and last name when
you talk to him it's not Brian Cal it's
- so Brian right so a fool yeah boy yeah
boy yeah you know [ __ ] boy come on
Matthew it was not very sensitively
socks yeah come on eat that don't know
the climate and you're a teacher you
find a friend named eat dick you're out
just with that dick oh [ __ ] I got a girl
boys all right just close it out I sold
out me and Brian will be there Thursday
Friday Saturday Brian is Denver 827 to
829 thing's still shut down I might be
there with you be so I like city for me
it's sold out we're gonna add a show
Thursday so if you're thirsty for
tickets we are a no-show Thursday spoken
we rescheduled it's July 30th through
August first and also the first thing
boy by club ride is Salt Lake City that
is July 18th
sign up at sick boy ride at gmail.com to
get details and to get sign up because
if you don't sign up can't come to the
ride and that's July 18th in Salt Lake
City the first eggnog row thick boy bike
club ride Spokane Washington
the second ride is August 1st all right
for details sign up thick boy ride at
gmail.com so I'm in Salt Lake City spoke
in and then in August I'm an Irvine
those ticks will be on sale soon all
right all right guys be nice each other
is that it be that's it but great cool I
just to find kid we're out